is the hijab 10
discount code for 10 discount on a wide
range of products including
premium ethiopian black seed products
assalamu alaikum warahmatullahi
yes there is something different yes
there is something unusual
yes there is something that might be a
little bit irritating but don't worry
we'll get rid of ali dawa
today guys what we're going to be doing
is we're going to be responding to some
of the comments made by
a comedian by the name of russell peters
so let's see some of his comments ali
and let's uh comment on those
okay let's do that inshallah yeah okay
so this video was sent to me by brother
and i thought
let's go for inshallah because he's
claimed to be an atheist
really well yeah because he was
essentially an atheist i am as well
yeah you ready yeah uh and he really
you know i remember this one routine
about the you know
whenever you go to a funeral at some
point someone's gonna say
i know he's up there looking down at us
and smiling yeah
you know i was like there is no up there
yeah he's he's probably down there
looking up at us religion has
convinced that there's an invisible man
and is living in the sky exactly
he's watching everything you do but he's
particularly keen on what you do with
your penis
okay let's take a step at a time yeah
yeah so
what i'm starting to realize is this
year so we know in the west for example
a lot of people have turned their back
to christianity yeah due to secularism
and
or the i think what they do a lot of
people do is like
they have a bad experience i think this
is human psychology they have a bad
experience with something
and then they paint everybody the same
so i think where he's coming from is
like it's the same thing because we hear
over and over again with atheists
oh yeah you guys believe in a man in the
sky well that's not really the case
as muslims do we believe in a man in the
sky or this
invisible being or etc because it's
something islamically
we actually laugh at you know we say
look this is actually nonsense
so what would you say to it let's let's
let's imagine russell peters is watching
this
right what would you say to him do you
as a muslim believe in a man in the sky
well if that's the god he doesn't
believe in then that's the god we all
don't believe in as muslims as well
yeah i mean right i mean
you know people don't realize that when
you come into islam you say two things
you say
and then obviously
so i testify that there's no god worthy
of worship
except for allah and that muhammad is
his messenger but the first part of that
is a negation
right so there is no god
worthy of worship except for allah right
so this negation actually cancels out
all anthropomorphic understandings of
god meaning so it's not right he can
come the same
or are you saying that you don't believe
in any other man gods
but the man good we don't believe in a
man god okay so we don't we don't
believe in any man god right because
you're special we don't believe in so no
man gods but our man god is different
no we don't believe in any man can be
god in fact
we don't think it's intelligible
conceivable or pardonable
that we can point at any man with a date
of birth and say that that
man is god okay i mean you're right
edward
so anyone with a date of birth that you
look at and you point to that person
yes we can't point to anybody like that
and say that that person is god because
god is by definition pre-eternal
and post-eternal god is the necessary
being
the sovereign
i made a joke it just went over there i
called edward i called you edward
because you used such a sophisticated
language and you sounded like an edward
i'm sorry
it was a joke that went bad why are you
saying that you know
us ethnics can't say clever
so um yeah it's not possible that so
we don't look at any human being and say
that's god in fact the quran is candid
about this
issue the quran is unequivocal about the
issue that there is no human being that
can be god
so we also reject that kind of god
with him we're on the same page on that
we'd reject a man god looking up and
pointing out
you know us from the sky whatever it may
be we do believe in a transcendental god
we do believe in a god that is all
powerful or wise or knowledgeable
because we look at the fact that the
universe
is in is finely tuned we look at the
fact that the universe
has laws and we attribute to that a law
maker
yeah that's as simple as that really we
attribute a lawmaker with intelligence
uh with power and it's not the case i'm
a new atheist and he's really kind of
regurgitating new atheist jargon here
they usually straw man religion before
they can
try and attack it these conceptions of
god is something we don't accept
exactly i might go to church and i'd be
like doesn't add up to me in here
just something seems off and
and i had questions and you weren't
allowed to ask questions
and i'm like well that seems a little
odd okay so
asking questions maybe he's talking
about
christianity um god knows
medieval times where you know they were
i found a mistake in
burning people who are involved in
science and all these kind of things
so is he coming from the angle where
he's saying well hold on a second i want
to ask questions you don't even allow me
to ask questions then you want me to
believe in that
to be fair even to christianity i don't
even think it's like i wouldn't even
characterize it like that you know
obviously people point out to galileo as
um but most historians of science they
don't see that as
because he said we spoke of the
heliocentric model there's a lot more
that came into it
i don't think any rational actor in the
world doesn't allow
or a community of rational people don't
allow questions to be asked
certain things would be even christians
and jews and muslims
religious people we have been asking
critical questions for
god god knows how long that is so i
don't even accept his anecdote as
generalizable right it's sometimes it
can be true that okay well maybe he's
asked some certain questions about the
trinity or certain question about the
man god
and he wasn't given a satisfactory
answer and we don't think christianity
has satisfactory answers for those
questions because remember they do
believe in a man god
but once again we shouldn't kind of
superimpose christian ideas on islam
and that's what i think he's done he
said religion is all one thing
um and basically it's all it's all one
kind of thing and
it's it's really not so he's not being
sophisticated in his response here
yeah exactly you know i think i think
sometimes i believe some certain
atheists they
they're looking for an excuse not to
believe and they
have one bad experience and they'll be
like okay i'll hold onto this for the
rest of my life if anybody asks me why
not
oh this is the reason why and sometimes
fooling yourself you know because then
they the signs of god around you let's
suppose christianity or whether they
didn't
tell you uh like for example you know
how many people we know that came to
islam yeah in the church they didn't let
me ask they didn't go and say okay i'm
to be an atheist they said no
there has to be a creator it's just this
doesn't make sense to me they're not
allowing me to ask questions okay i'll
go to another church and ask questions
it's not sufficient enough
you don't just hold that on and be like
okay i think it's like a card that you
use where
you make your nest feel better and be
like no no you know i seek the truth
they didn't give me so
i'm just going to live my life how i
want to see good point
because the the signs of allah you know
verses over versus what it talks about
even
in your own self you know if you're not
going to question that i don't know man
i feel you i'm an atheist myself yeah i
mean i was probably a jew at some point
i was raised jewish actually yeah i was
raised jewish but at one point i mean i
haven't gone to a synagogue and
he paused it just one thing i he says
you're probably a jew at one point so
i think there's an assumption here which
is that whenever he thinks that
socialization can only happen towards
religion and you can't be socialized
into atheism
you know to be honest one time i'll tell
you something interesting right um
i was doing something when i was working
as a teacher i was asking the kids in my
classroom
i was asking them if they knew what
atheism was and if they knew what
christianity was and
all those things because there were key
terms right and then i asked follow-up
questions who would identify as an
atheist who'd identifies
uh christian who and so on and i would
say the majority of kids in the
classroom put their hands up
in identifying as an atheist then i said
what is atheism and those same kids
that put their hands up when when i
asked them what is atheism
sorry what would you identify as they
didn't know what atheism
entailed in in even a basic way
so you can be socialized into atheism
just as you can be socialized into
christianity
it's it's this um this idea of
neutrality has to be argued for
if you want to say that well atheism is
a neutral
thing yeah but you have to argue that
that is the case are people born
believing in atheism because
actually there were studies was it was
oxford university yeah
2011 the anthropological society they
said that most people are born believing
in high power
so so we can say the neutral position is
you're all believers right but
as an intellectual position as an
intellectual position we both have to
make arguments
we have to show why that is the neutral
position but he hasn't done that he
assumes that to be the case
yeah but he hasn't shown any evidence
for it yeah exactly it's true very very
important
but my whole goal is just listen at the
end of the day
did i do good things and nice things for
people when i was here that's all i care
about yeah
and i think we can end on this point
here this what he just mentioned did i
do good things that's what i care about
we've discussed this before what's good
thing good who defines what goodness is
good who does who do you prioritize
being good too right and if we think
about in our
sense like we live here and on this
planet on this earth
being good i think what would you say
who should you be the most kind to
let's let's put it like who would you
say you should be the most kind to who
deserves your
most gratitude and kindness and for you
to obey like
let's not let's particularly got out the
picture for a second who would you say
like
me i was like my parents okay yeah and
then uh maybe after that
i don't know maybe my brother i don't
know maybe then my wife or my kids i
don't know yeah
there's hierarchy yeah because you know
okay well the thing is we believe in a
creator
then the definition a lot of people come
and ask this question okay you know
mother teresa where she going to go i'm
like look if you understand what shirk
is
and what the what shirk means if you are
good to everybody if ali dawa is good to
everyone charitable everybody loves
alidawah his child children he helps
everybody
when he goes home he insults his mom he
beats his mom up is ali dawa a good
person
everyone's going to say no hold on a
second i'm good to everybody then how do
you expect the treatment of entering
paradise in the hereafter when you're
going to go to god and say god i was
good to every
everyone i was good to but you
disobeying the commandments
of allah um and not acknowledging him
and not
maybe some some people who hate god then
how are you a good person i think we
need to understand the redefine what is
good
well it's a good point i mean at the end
of the day like you say um
goodness is a metaphysic it's not
something which is empirically uh
justified
you can't put goodness under a
microscope and so
yeah you can't put goodness under from
his point of view goodness doesn't exist
if you're a materialist naturalist
materialist okay
atheist you can't actually talk about
morality in any meaningful objectively
objectively meaningful way because you
can't put morality under a microscope
and so goodness is going to be totally
subjective
it's going to be something which is a
social construct or a cultural construct
of some sort
and therefore something which you
shouldn't be using as an argument
and so that on the flip side as well the
problem of evil becomes redundant for an
atheist because
evil is unprovable it's a metaphysically
unprovable thing
so once again when atheists like this
individual
says mentions goodness and you know
badness if you like you know
is he talking about something which
exists objectively in the real world
and if so how can you prove it you know
demonstrably
how can you show us you know because
it's not empirically uh justified just
in the same way as you would say
god is not something you can put under a
microscope therefore i don't believe him
so if you want to have your cake then
you can't have your cake and eat it both
if you if you want to reject
metaphysical um explanations for for
example why we're here
then also you have to uh reject
metaphysical morality matter
all kinds of metaphysics exactly yeah so
so to be honest instead of calling it
the economy come and call it the problem
of evil can we call it like
the problem of nothingness or the
problem of the atoms because you know if
you think about
you can't come and talk about evil and
good because you're an atheist
so you can't even come to me with the
problem of evil absolutely an atheist
for me
um cannot claim that or you know cannot
prove
that evil or goodness objectively exists
they can't prove that and therefore
using it as an argument against
religion or for atheism or for morality
irreligious morality
is really a redundant it's a moot point
and uh it doesn't get you far
and broken sisters on that note do not
forget to subscribe
to my channel um it's on your channel
i don't know whose channel is going to
be well watch it obviously on your
channel
okay you watch the video on hijab
channel please subscribe to my channel
you're going to do that you're going to
subscribe to his channel so you can
always be bombarded with the most
ridiculous
content until next time assalamu alaikum
you